jamie mazzini as we can see on the
screen guys i'm on his page now yeah
if we go to for example this specific
video yeah so what he does is
he goes to shopping malls and he just
gives that money
and it seems like from the outset like
when you look but he seems like a good
samaritan if you love his style for now
there is nothing more scary than
standing in front of allah on the day of
judgment
if you make a sin made you say whatever
you can repent for it but the people's
haqq what the people earned
you taking that from them is
james in if you're watching this
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
don't forget to like share and subscribe
otherwise you're going to be finished
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah before i start when i praise
allah subhanahu wa talah the most most
for the most trust or praise his glory
and gratitude belong to him
i've been avoided in this video many
reasons brother sisters when these
issues come up sometimes people like to
behave like a hero yeah i'm going to go
save the day
you know let me come and you know people
need to understand all these things it's
actually disease of the heart
um if as social influences public
figures especially looking for content
to just jump on things like
you know i need to go you know yeah i
need to be the hero of the day and i
need to save the day and uh
you know we need to really question our
intentions for one year i've had people
messaging me
uh about this specific brother he's a
muslim brother
um and i've been avoiding it because in
the context i don't
know people message me from america i
think from new york like please actually
look into this
etc and i'm like bro genuinely do not
have the time and also
i don't know and i can't be everywhere
brother well i genuinely cannot be
everywhere i'm not superman
and i'm no one special there are many
people out there who can do a uh
but the mata resonated a bit home
because me and a lot of family uh well
i'll say family members
i'll say um friends close friends
people that i knew people that i did
work with uh be a little bit of business
transactions etc whatever it may be
a lot of people got affected and was
lost nearly about
two million pounds in total maybe we're
talking about hundreds of people here
yeah
um and this was a some kind of a scam
another person i was involved with
where i was a middleman um and i believe
this person
um was innocent he himself got scammed
uh the person that i was kind of being a
middleman to
and because everyone was just looking
for halal income it's good to do halal
income business etc
i'm not gonna get into the details it
gets a bit messy but the reason i'm
mentioning this is because this is
very close to heart and people that i
know even certain single mothers
invested their funds into this there's
certain people invest their money
and they lost their money we lost our
money um a lot of people lost a lot of
money
some people became greedy and went
direct like that i was a middle guy
usually i would
refer people i was uh just one of those
and people that i referred etc
some people made money and it all starts
off like that you know um that you
make some money between uh what you
invest between what eight
to twelve percent and you get back which
we should be alarmed but we just thought
you know what
it seems like a legitimate legitimate
business uh it's coming from someone
that we trust
uh but that person that we trusted sadly
he was
um okay so he was also the victim of
that even though
certain mistakes were made exceptionally
let's not get into that so now when i
message uh about jay mazzini uh jay
mazzini as you can see on the screen
guys i'm on his page now yeah
um if we go to for example this specific
video yeah so what he does is
he goes to shopping malls and he just
gives that money and i saw this video
about a year and a half ago
and i was like yeah it seems like from
the outset like when you look like he's
got all these ps5s in his
um in in the basket yeah i don't know
what he's doing with it
uh but he seems like a good samaritan
because he was giving money to different
people
um over here i don't know what exactly
he's doing let's just fold a bit
are you kidding me so okay so as you can
see
he's giving out ps5s yeah he's
interested in ps5 and the subtitle
um we know how hard it is to get subhan
allah that if you watch brotherhood
video soon coming out they will tell you
the story how we got a ps5 spanner all
the way from california
look so he's given he's giving out ps5s
this is just one uh there's instances
where he's going to um
let's see let's see let's see what else
it's five thousand five thousand i
thought give it to her that's five
thousand for her
that's five thousand for you i'm showing
low
got my brother fabulous right here
what's up
so that's that's the rapper fabulous
yeah um
he's he's he's working with these um
well he's getting
famous people on board as well etc and
he's giving that money so i've seen
sometimes where he's just like throwing
cash out like his happy days
now the question that needs to be asked
is why would somebody do that you know
and he's got a clothing company which if
i'm not mistaken you know
um i haven't realized this with my
teachers but
for someone to have a clothing company
and say that for the next hundred orders
i'm gonna put
thirty thousand dollars that's it that's
haram because in the context you're
actually selling money for money because
it's like
you're it might be classes everybody
yeah is that you're saying okay people
are gonna go and people are gonna it's
not gambling you know let me
give money and i'm gonna get more money
yeah and and this is not permissible but
that's not the crux of the matter it's
not a big deal in that context where it
is
but what i'm trying to say guys is when
you go to his profile he's just out
there
throwing money to different kinds of
people yeah like here's another one here
so he's going up
to people and he's just um
so that he will go
so as you can see guys here what he's
doing there he's just going and giving
money now
a lot of people have messaged and said
that he's been actually
scamming people i tried messaging him so
look if we go to his profile and we'll
go to
uh the messaging section here i messaged
him 11 december yeah last year
assalamu alaikum i hope you're well uh
we have many people contacting us that
you have been you have taken money from
the muslims
but haven't returned the funds we would
like to speak to you to clarify as this
a man
of the people i'm not accusing you but
would want to hear your side
uh uh yeah so basically
the question is this problem says the
way this works and the way me and people
in the uk got scammed by
uh sadly people like his likes is that
they will get this money it's like a
it's it's like a ponzi scheme yeah and
then what they will do is they'll
distribute this money they'll return it
back to you
yeah so you're giving this 10 of you
guys given 30 grand yeah they will come
and say to you all right here he goes
here's your first uh return yeah 800
pounds or a thousand pounds whatever it
may be yeah so they give 30 people
that thousand pounds i know you're
thinking wow it's actually working but
the thing is when it comes to taking
your initial investment back
that's where things go pear shaped
because you're ruining the whole scheme
when you ask your funds to come back
because they are rotating that money
they're going to another 30 people
getting that money
giving some to you your fee you're
getting gas you're getting hyped you
know what we're making money
you're investing more then they're
giving you a little bit more and you're
thinking yeah it's going good and
they're
they're just moving they're cycling the
funds like that until they reach the
point is big enough and then they
disappear or they make excuses yeah
now there's a specific guy who's dealing
uh with this uh uh for and
speaking to the victims and i highly
urge for you guys
uh inshallah to um follow uh
follow his works because he's going in
that he's made multiple videos
of this specific guy as you can see he's
made multiple videos on him
yeah now the thing is brothers and
sisters the rights of the people
when it comes to taking one pound off a
person that's
hacked this is right you're in deep deep
trouble in the hereafter
you're a muslim if you're a believer for
you to take people's money now let me
take this let me make this right
it might be the fact that this guy has a
good intention it might be the fact
the very person that i was working with
i believe he has good intentions
but those good intentions doesn't it
it's not
enough for you to have a business
transaction you might be someone i might
be a good samaritan i want to help
people
and i lie to them and i say for example
i want to make this investment etc
i tell you guys i'm going to be
investing in this and that and that
whatever it may be
and but in return i'm going to invest in
something else
that is not permissible because we are
investing on that very specific item an
apple
you go and invest in bricks for example
yeah
and because of that you lose the funds
that is not permissible
even if you wanted to give us a return
ten times tenfold
uh tenfold the amount it's not
permissible
so this guy may have been good intended
person who wanted to do the good for the
um etc let's say argument saying say
that yeah
even if you do that you're still not
permissible for you to do that
or secondly is an outright scammer yeah
an outright
food star a scammer and it seems like
the more he's silent
the more this is what's happening if you
go watch these videos in this guy's
channel he's a non-muslim
yeah if you go to his channel
coffeezilla he is basically telling
people to smell the coffee started to
smell the coffee
you know brothers and sisters and while
these things ruin people's lives yeah
sadly myself even though i'm not to
blame i was a middleman for a specific
issue that happened spanning a couple of
years ago where a lot of people lost
their money i lost my money my family
members
lost their money yeah till this day to
this day
myself and uh certain family members
are having to pay out and not that we
have to but we don't have good
will because certain people's money was
invested which they were elderly etc
and we can't just and we're paying out
of our own pocket to
um because their situation and we wanted
good for these families we said you know
what there's an investment that's
happening this halal is permissible
etc and we want you guys to benefit our
intentions were right
but sadly we got uh you know scammed and
subhanallah till this day a lot of
people are paying those funds and even
so that certain people
it got a bit greedy and went directly to
this other person
and they lost massive amounts of money
massive
and i would have personally stopped them
individuals but i had no
um no i didn't know the matter so sadly
this is what greed does to you it shows
you the reality to of a lot of people uh
you know
so it's it's sad but what i'm just
trying to say about the sisters is that
the specific instance that these
scammers
i know and there was another guy another
scumbag i'm going to call him the scum
of this earth
and he would go to masajid he would go
and try to take pictures with mufti
manga and my pictures etc
to use our pictures and be like oh i
know these guys etc and we'll try to go
and scan masajid scum religious people
they go specifically for religious
people and as muslims sometimes we're
naive
we look at the other individual he's a
brother he wouldn't do that he's a
believer he practices
brothers and sisters when it comes to
money yeah
you see different faces you do see
different phases trust me when it comes
to money
you see the reality of a person
subhanallah so brothers and sisters
we ask allah to protect us from this
fitnah and wallahi i'm saying this to
brother jay
if you're watching james i don't know
his name is james mazzini
yeah i'm telling you aki wallahi if this
is what you're doing you need to feel
all subpoenaed
yeah and i heard that you was even uh i
don't know if this is true you have to
come and clarify i don't you need to
come and clarify yeah
not to me you have the clarified people
that you're threatening people's wives
et cetera yeah if this is
true this cowardly act you're a coward
if this if this is true i'm not saying
if this is true this is a cowardly act
here if you intended to do something
good
things flopped come out and say brothers
i'm sorry that's what i wanted to do
it didn't happen but if your intentions
is to
scam people take this money live a
lavish lifestyle
live your lifestyle for now i'm telling
you
there is nothing more scary than
standing in front of allah on the day of
judgment
if you make a sin made you say whatever
you can repent for it but the people's
hak
what the people earned you taking that
from them
is the sight of allah it is one of the
major sins
and it is a sin it's not something that
you can just repent for
you have to ask for their forgiveness or
you have to pay them back
it's as simple as that that is how deep
this matter
is that on the day of judgment there's
going to be a specific location
where people have crossed the serrat and
in that very location i can't remember
the name
is where if anybody has wronged anybody
if i have backbitten and slandered yeah
i've backbeaten and slandered like these
s-pubs that do these
uh these enemies of uh muslims yeah
they're gonna stand there
yeah these people like uh yeah they're
going to stand up yeah they're going to
stand on their judgment
and they are going to give their good
deeds to the people that they slandered
the people that they took their rights
of the muslims if they don't have any
good deeds
yeah and if they don't repent they are
going to carry the burdens the sins of
the people that they're backed by to
look at the justice of allah
this is how just allah subhanahu wa is
that the hadith of the process
said that an animal with horns that
attacked another animal that didn't have
horns
on that day will be given horns to get
his justice
to to the level of animals jameson if
you're watching this
fear allah and those scammers out there
brothers and sisters if there's any
in the subhanallah um in in the
community
expose them expose these people you know
uh and
wallahi brothers and sisters it is
something to be feared we ask allah to
protect us
and james send this video to him watch
the videos that coffeezilla's youtube
channel
i'm going to put it there um and
inshallah protect us because this
destroys lives
me speaking to sisters single mothers
coming and saying brother what happened
this person got me involved they said
you was doing it
well i feel terrible i feel terrible
that people got involved and we all lost
money where we wanted to earn halal
income
uh so brahma sisters i'm i'm for now
this is the video just a video to jay
mazzini and to tell you guys
what happened here in the uk to us and a
lot of brothers um
and sisters so um many maybe more videos
will come out as we see things
progressing i'm going to be getting
contact with
coffeezilla inshallah brothers and
sisters this matters serious uh and we
we're in sha are going to
uh be dealing with it uh till now till
now you can watch the videos on the
channels that we said to you guys
inshallah
and if anybody comes to you with an
offer that is too good to be true
it probably is and stay away from it do
not trust people based on their
religiosity
like i said before his decision imam is
a mufti irrelevant
you do it on a inshallah in an islamic
way
in the right way do your due diligence
inshallah and don't trust anybody
if you see something fishy stay away
from if it sounds too good to be true it
probably is
especially with those kind of returns
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi
w